we talk about this so-called patriarchy  but it's women who are valued more than  men we want equality but like what does  equality even mean I think women are  intrinsically valued on a higher level  to men because it's the women and the  children that are always protected first  it's the men that are sent off to war  it's the men that are more disposable as  a man like I said you have to become and  a woman can just be so it's like Society  doesn't care about you until you become  something and nobody wants to talk about  that and I think we should talk about it  I think the Dynamics between men and  women would just be better with healthy  masculinity femininity can thrive in  that kind of space and if we stop men  from being masculine and we stop women  from being feminine the genders just  melt into each other and it becomes a  mess